qu'est ce que vous faisiez la récré
c'est à dire en faisait des rondes que
maintenant qu'ils ont pu s'amuser et
elle est surveillée par par les
asymétries c'était sévère barre si oui
parce que je me rappelle qu'un jour
j'avais riz avec ma voisine ou mamie
d'appliquer
me souvenais co jouant bach et
comprenait des drôles de cou a dit hé
souvent
or en terre avec des habits déchirés
c'est pendant la récréation qu'on
organise pas même des activités
collectives
c'est pendant la récréation pour se
situer par rapport aux autres même
lorsqu'on reçoit quelques coups
les bagarres sont en effet parfois très
sévères dont ce monde qui semble si
chloé si dur
et même sous cette forme
mais s'agit-il toujours de vraies
bagarres suivons l'enfant de droite au
pull over rouge il simule la bagarre
mais ne la fait pas
en revanche les deux enfants collés aux
murs vont réellement se battre
ils se portent les coûts appuyé
[Applaudissements]
attachons plus l'importance au simulacre
de la bagarre
les coups bas mais n'atteignent pas leur
but
parfois ça prend la forme d'un véritable
ballet
[Applaudissements]
la bagarre est davantage symboliser que
réelle
[Applaudissements]
dans de nombreux cas c'est le contact
corporel qui prévaut chez les enfants de
tous les âges il y est en effet un
besoin de contacts corporels en dehors
de toute menace de toute bagarre
et même dans ce cas l'otage
bénéficie de la caresse de celui qui l'a
attrapée
ici les enfants s'en lasse
toujours ce besoin corporelle qui joue
un très grand rôle dans la tolérance
mutuelle et dans l'élaboration
d'activités en commun
c'est l'une des clés de la socialisation
de la coopération
[Applaudissements]
qui dort
et navals une femme
parce que tout le monde ils m'attaquent
alors je n'aime pas une donne des coups
de pieds alors quand je les donne a rit
pleure
tu te fais
[Musique]
tout à l'heure il ya trop bande dans la
course et les bandas qui
réagissent 3 bat danois
une bande manuel oui
si ce
monstre une petit mais alors il ya celle
d'emmanuel celle de franck qui m'a dit
qu'un avait 3 et l'enfant ont une et
puis vous allez mal non enfin la bande
de tir les faits qu'elle le sait une
bande tu peux me le sida et ses plaines
copains plein de copains qu'ils ont faim
a
assez plein de copains qui sont forts et
attirer une voiture et est ce que
quelqu'un pour que tous les otages
thierry on a beaucoup avec moi
oui
il est obligé pourquoi
pour être encore plus que correct plus
fort
fort quand sarah on n'a pas entendu tout
à l'heure je t'ai demandé jeudi pourquoi
tout le monde ne pouvait pas faire
partie de la bande à boris et affront du
tout vient de ce que tu m'as répondu
parce que y'en a qui les attaquent les
se fera que a peut-être d'autres
d'autres enfants et ce l'est veulent pas
jouer avec eux avez-vous les attaquer et
qu'est ce que vous pensez des enfants
qui appâtent qui se bat on pensait
faire
il ya des bagarres ya les bagarres
surtout dans ce quartier où les enfants
sont ont besoin de se défouler ont
besoin de se détendre et ont souvent une
agressivité du fait du milieu familial
s'est pas toujours les mêmes qui se
bagarrent souvent si c'est toujours les
mêmes qui furent vraiment laid le
caractère d'agressivité on les retrouve
toujours
c'est en effet toujours les mêmes
enfants qui expriment les agressions les
plus fréquentes et les plus violentes
lorsqu'un enfant agressif perd la
bataille il a tendance à s'isoler
regardons de plus près comment se
comporte un enfant agressif en remontant
à l'école maternelle suivant l'enfant ou
pullover grille
ils menacent
ils essayent d'attirer l'attention des
autres sur lui
mais il provoque tout au plus des actes
de crainte
n'ayant pas obtenu la communication avec
les autres il s'éloigne seul
il tente une nouvelle fois
d'attirer l'attention d'un enfant mais
il n'arrive qu'à déclencher sur lui une
agression à laquelle il répond de façon
très violente
[Musique]
puis comme dans le cas précédent
l'enfant agressif va avoir tendance à
s'isoler de lui même
[Applaudissements]
d'autres enfants en revanche entraîne
souvent la traction des autres
[Musique]
suivant la petite fille en blanc
se mettant à quatre pattes elle provoque
l'arrivée de plusieurs enfants
ce type d'enfant que nous avons appelée
leader constitue le pôle d'attraction et
d'entraînement des autres ils sont aussi
des plus inventifs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'école primaire on retrouve les mêmes
phénomènes
ici le leader et plus grand pull blanc
vient de désamorcer menace mme
puis comme précédemment il entraîne
l'arrivée de plusieurs autres enfants
l'enfant qui entraîne le leader
est suivie par les autres lorsqu'il
s'éloigne
et c'est autour de lui que vont
s'organiser les activités des autres
tout se fait en référence à lui
le leader ici l'enfant au tricot rayé
est également celui qui offre souvent
tout en exprimant des comportements de
ce type à valeur apaisante
c'est grâce à de tels comportements et
la présence des leaders que des groupes
se forment comme ici dans des
tourbillons un coordonnées
[Applaudissements]
ou bien ils se forment des activités
organisées collective
toujours
avec des leaders au départ
tous les enfants et figure à l'exception
des enfants isolés
dominés
[Musique]
en général les enfants qui refusent la
récréation sur les enfants qui ne sont
pas admis dans un groupe et les enfants
qui sont isolées pour eux la récréation
ce n'est pas agréable au contraire c'est
une sorte de son complexe et il n'arrive
pas vraiment à s'intégrer j'ai eu des
exemples de petits pour la récréation
c'était un calvaire et qu'ils étaient
dans la cour il se mettait dans un coin
et puis terminé il attendait la première
récréation avec impatience
certains enfants se retrouvent en effet
souvent coupée des autres
comme ici où ils suivent la maîtresse et
les mettre
c'est le refus jeu ils ne risquent pas
ainsi de s'attribuer les agressions des
autres
[Musique]
un autre enfant isolé dominé qui
n'essaye même pas d'entrer en relation
avec les autres
ce type d'enfants ne parvient pas à
s'intégrer aux activités déjà organisé
[Musique]
et même chez ceux qui sont plus âgés on
retrouve ce phénomène
l'enfant est à l'écart des autres
la récréation est finie
mais il s'est passé une foule de choses
c'est en effet pendant la récréation que
chaque enfant parvient à se situer par
rapport aux autres
c'est là qu'ils mettent en place les
processus de socialisation
et on sait maintenant il ya différents
types de comportements qui sont le
reflet de l'influencé de la famille
[Musique]